- Welcome back to the show.
I'm Mark Ellis and we
have a returning favorite,
the French tuck.
- Oh, okay.
- Speaking of returning champions,
we have The Rock.
He's back in another episode
and he still is not
gonna make it in person?
No?
Looking for parking?
Okay.
He's not here, that's unfortunate,
but I am and so let's go ahead
and pit the igneous one
versus a hilarious comic,
a box office star,
and a frequent collaborator
of Dwayne Johnson,
Mr. Kevin Hart.
They're teaming up again
for Jumanji 2, 2 Jungle 2 Furious,
but today it's all about
whose career is more fire.
Kevin Hart, who I met a few times
when I worked the door
at the comedy store,
he was very nice,
or The Rock, who one time
retweeted a friend of mine.
- What?
- Here's how it works.
Round one, box office,
round two, Tomatometer,
round three, versatility,
and then we'll do a wild card round.
I'll render my verdict
and lastly, I'll turn it
over to you the viewer
for your vote.
Ready to go?
The winner plays Jack Black next.
Let's get it on.
- Straight out of the Jabroni beating.
Pie eating, trail
blazing, eyebrow raising,
entertaining the globe never hotter,
talking to two rejects from Harry Potter.
- Whoa.
- Round one, box office.
Whether we're going to the cinema
for laughs, explosions,
or just to mindlessly shove popcorn
in our faces for two hours,
both The Rock and Kevin Hart fit the bill.
Dwayne came from the world of wrestling
to save the day on the big screen.
Then we found out he's really funny, too.
- Because I have a secret weapon.
People actually like me.
- [Mark] Kevin came from
the world of stand up
to make his gig on the big screen.
Then we found out he's even
funny in action flicks.
Kevin puts up a good fight against Dwayne
for the best domestic box office numbers.
His movies have grossed
a combined $3 billion
with a per flick average of $94 million.
That's just short of
Dwayne's domestic total
of $4.3 billion and $134
million per movie average.
So we got us a good ball game here, right?
Well then we go international.
Apparently giant action sequences
travel better overseas than laughs
as evidenced by The Rock's films
grossing a combined
$12.2 billion worldwide.
- Woman, I am the calvary.
- Wow.
Is that?
Do we have that much
money on Earth, still?
Meanwhile, Kevin Hart's films
have done $5.5 billion total of business,
so when it comes to box office,
I don't wanna say that Kevin
has been torched by Dwayne,
so I won't, I will not say that.
- A height joke.
That was good, that's original.
- I'll just give Rocky the win
and we'll move on to round number two.
- It just happens naturally.
- Round number two, Tomatometer.
This is a round Kevin Hart needs to win,
in order for him to have a chance
and for this vid to be compelling.
Both fellows hover around the 50% mark
for their average movie
on the Tomatometer.
The Rock is at 50.3%, Hart is 45.3%.
If we look specifically at comedies,
it gets a little more competitive.
Kevin Hart's funny flicks average 45.7%,
while Johnson's average 46.3%.
Dwayne's best work,
according to the Tomatometer,
is Fighting With My Family at 92%.
His highest comedy
is the hilarious The Other Guys at 78%.
- You thinking what I'm thinking, partner?
- Aim for the bushes.
- [Mark] Kevin Hart has
a perfect 100% rating
for his stand-up special, Irresponsible,
although to be fair, it
only has six reviews.
- You attacked my comedy specials,
you selfless bastards?
- [Mark] He's also one of the
stars of Captain Underpants
and that's at 88%.
And Top Five, the Chris Rock
film that he appears in,
that's at 86%.
So look, both gents have
some really good movies,
some of which they've been in together
and their averages are neck in neck.
What's gonna determine
a winner in this round
is who has the least amount
of truly awful garbage
stinking up the bottom of the vine.
Kevin sets the bar really high, low,
whatever you wanna call it,
with Little Fockers.
It's currently 9% on the Tomatometer.
The Rock's low bar is another attempt
at family pleasing humor,
The Tooth Fairy, at 18%.
- Oh my gosh, the magic wand.
Gonna break, man.
- So I guess because Dwayne's
movie has a higher score,
he'll get the win,
wait a minute, what's that I hear?
Good god, that's Baywatch's music.
Yes, The Rock starred in a
movie that is truly awful,
not just for our time, but for all times.
- I scratch my back with a whale's dick.
- How that dead pile of seaweed
made it all the way to 18% on
the Tomatometer is beyond me,
and so now that I'm presented
with this new information,
I cannot in good conscious
award this round to The Rock.
Kevin Hart takes the
Tomatometer set in an upset,
and now we're tied at one apiece.
♪ One two three four ♪
(singing in foreign language)
- Round three, versatility.
This round feels like a trap
and despite Admiral Ackbar
yelling that in my ear,
I'm gonna continue.
- It's a trap!
- Who's more versatile, got more range,
who can do more things better?
Kevin Hart, not only is he a funny actor,
he's a comic that sells out
arenas all over the globe,
which is two different
skill sets, kiddies.
- I don't trust people that
do this when they talk.
- [Mark] He also is a producer,
he has his own company,
and here's something that gets overlooked,
in the films he stars
in alongside The Rock,
like Jumanji and Central Intelligence,
he's a really good straight man.
He allows Dwayne to be the comedic one.
- I'm swaddling you.
- I know what you're doing.
- [Mark] To be a comic that
is on stage by yourself
in front of tens of thousands of people,
and then to be able to
check that ego at the door
to allow your costar to shine,
that's impressive.
- Me, me, me, me.
- What's even more impressive?
The Rock.
- I'm offended.
- His nickname is Franchise
Viagra for a reason
and most people would be
content with that reputation,
but with Dwayne,
that's just the tip of
the proverbial iceburg.
He's an athlete,
wrestler, actor, producer,
and his social media accounts
are just a bit more
popular than Kevin Hart.
The Rock has more followers
on Instagram and YouTube,
while Kevin has more on
the cesspool of darkness.
I'm sorry, that's Twitter.
I read that wrong.
- When you use a bird to write
with, it's called tweeting.
- [Mark] Within the context of movies,
Dwayne also has shown more range.
- That is the pec-pop of love.
- [Mark] He can play the tough badass,
the charming spy, the
tough badass charming spy.
- I love your babooshka.
- But he can also be the sensitive dad,
an introspective coach,
basically Dwayne can be
anyone with a heart of gold
on either side of the law.
- You're welcome.
- Plus he can go insanely
evil, like in Doom.
- We kill 'em all.
- No, anybody, remember?
Am I not supposed to bring that up?
Scorpion King, anyone?
Great effects.
Both gentlemen boast an
impressive amount of versatility,
but at the end of the day,
The Rock does not sleep, ever.
Like he doesn't sleep.
There is no way he can,
hang on, I'm just getting word now,
he's also a tequila magnate?
Jeez, while Vin Diesel
is napping his life away,
The Rock continues to blaze a trail
very few could of predicted
and leaves footsteps
that no one can follow
and that's the bottom line.
- And that's the bottom line.
- Oh yeah, it's Stone Cold.
That's not.
Well, I smell what The Rock is cooking,
and that's a victory
in round number three.
- (laughing) Stop it, stop it.
- Wild card round.
Who's the better troll?
Okay, so maybe The Rock
is more famous, versatile,
an overall heroic type,
but when it comes to
bro on bro tomfoolery,
he has met his match with Kevin Hart.
These two go at each other constantly
in the funniest, most good
natured surprising ways possible.
Kevin has been through some
real life stuff recently
and Dwyane is always there to poke fun
in a big brother sort of way.
When Hart had the Academy
Awards controversy,
Johnson joked that
it was Dwayne who in fact
was the first choice.
Then Kevin had a life
threatening car crash
and after expressing his honest
well wishes to his buddy,
The Rock then threw a jab
by saying that Kevin was safely
strapped to his car seat.
That's funny stuff.
- Thankfully he was strapped
in nicely to his car seat.
- But Kevin might have
had my favorite burn ever
in picture form.
They go back and forth
a ton on social media
and when Hart made his Halloween costume
an exact replica of a pic
from Dwayne Johnson's University
of Miami Hurricane's days
it won the Internet.
That is hysterical.
- All you gotta do is go the costume store
and say make me look stupid.
- The Rock was a good sport
and has plenty of ammo to retaliate with
including bringing this
childhood photo of Kevin Hart
to his most recent
appearance on Ellen's show.
- He's doing this.
I wish I was this tall.
- If you engage with social media,
these two are likely the top reason why.
Their back and forth represents
a roast battle yin and yang,
none would be whole without the other,
so the only reason I
give this round to Hart
is knowing him as a stand-up comic.
I know the firepower he has
to full on crush a heckler,
Dwayne is consistently funny,
inspiring and active across
all his many platforms,
but when it comes to having the ability
to troll another person,
I will always take the comic
who is shorter and has probably
heard that all his life,
'cause that person has an unlimited supply
of retaliation ready to go,
kind of like The Rock's
character, Luke Hobbs,
in the Fast and Furious flicks.
This round is going to Kevin Hart.
- Best case, I'ma abracadabra bitches.
You're looking at the magic.
- But the match itself goes
to Dwayne The Rock Johnson.
As much they're a great team,
I feel like The Rock
would be able to link up
with any number of comedic forces
and make magic together,
but Hart, what other action
star is he gonna join
and get the same results with?
The Rock is a singular
force on this planet
that should never be undersold.
♪ I was so handsome ♪
- Ow!
Scorching!
- I hate this game.
- That's just my opinion, folks.
Now the real heavy lifting is up to you.
Vote now simply by commenting below.
Who do you love more?
Who wins the rounds in your eyes?
Which actor would you
rather hang out with?
- Hey.
- Let us know,
and if The Rock or
Kevin Hart are watching,
just remember, guys,
please never ever, ever, ever
stop making fun of each other.
Always do that and let us see it,
especially if it involves a fanny pack,
a leather fanny pack to be exact.
Have a great day, gang.
I'm French tuck Ellis
and we'll see you next time.
(upbeat music)